[Music]  [Music]  knock it off  todd i think amber's been pretty clear  about how she feels  i'm nothing like my dad i want to be  just like you  i fought to keep this planet safe  your power's got to be due any day now  son  morning i'm scared dad what if i can't  do this  follow slow me  land i said land stop  get up i'm actually getting used to this  a little that's not good  need to be better after everything he's  done how can i live up to all that you  need to decide what kind of hero you  want to be that was you  in the blue and the yellow why don't you  meet the team after school may we count  on you in the future  yeah i think so and bored of this  [Music]  son we need to talk  what i'm about to tell you will change  everything  dad  [Music]  i wasn't ready before now i am  you being a superhero is the coolest  thing that's ever happened to me now  take me flying or i'm gonna tell  everyone you're invincible  sorry not sorry  [Music]  [Music]  you